[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS GRAY: Welcome to Google
Developers Live.
I'm Louis Gray from GDL, joined
today with two great
guests from the Google
Chrome team to talk
about Chrome Academy.
It's a brand new event coming
to Google this year.
We're here based in
Mountain View.
So I want to just start it off
by introducing Peter Lubbers
and Allison Roarty.
Thanks for joining me.
ALLISON ROARTY: Thank you.
LOUIS GRAY: Now Chrome Academy
is, as I mentioned, new.
It's the first time we've
ever done this.
And it's really taken all of
your time the last week, few
weeks past.
Maybe you can give our viewers
on the live stream an
understanding of what Chrome
Academy is all about.
ALLISON ROARTY: Absolutely.
So Chrome Academy is a week-long
development program
for university students
who are rising
sophomores and juniors.
And we're bringing them here to
Google for a week to teach
them about building web-packaged
Chrome apps.
LOUIS GRAY: OK.
PETER LUBBERS: Well, of
course, we're super
excited about it.
It's been a lot of fun
already this week.
But we also want to show you a
little bit of the reactions
from the students themselves.
And we created a little
video for them.
LOUIS GRAY: Cool.
JOHN MOORE: I was looking for
internships for this summer
around spring break of this
year, and I saw that Google
had a number of programs that
students, rising sophomores
and juniors, could
be involved in.
I saw Chrome Academy, and it
really caught my attention.
CATHERINE MULLINGS: I did a
summer program last summer
called Google Computer Science
Summer Institute.
And there they really introduce
students to HTML,
JavaScript, App Engine, and
all these resources.
And just being there for three
weeks, I really enjoyed the
culture that everyone brought.
Everyone was so excited to
build new technologies.
And so I just thought I should
be at Google again.
CALVIN CHAN: I believe it all
started with one of the career
fairs at UCLA.
I heard about it, and I went
there to check out a few of
the companies that were trying
to entice students to apply
for opportunities.
And I saw the Google booth and
talked to one the recruiters.
He introduced me to several of
the Google programs, and I was
specially interested in Chrome
Academy because I started
developing websites during
high school.
And it's definitely something
that I'm very interested in.
JONATHAN POON: I'll just
go ahead and apply.
And then luckily, I got in.
So I was really excited to
be part of this program.
CARA KESSLER: I would say that
my favorite part of the Chrome
Academy experience so far has
been the instructors that I've
met and that I've gotten
to speak with
on a personal level.
Before we came to Chrome
Academy, we were encouraged to
brush up on our skills
a little online.
So I did the Chrome
DevTools school.
And when I clicked on the
introduction video, there was
Paul Irish explaining how great
Chrome DevTools are.
And then three days later, I'm
at Google, and there's live
Paul Irish.
CALVIN CHAN: I think one of
the coolest things about
Chrome Academy is that I
personally am interested in
the type of courses that
are being offered here.
JONATHAN POON: I think it's
mainly just all the people
that I've met.
They were all very passionate
about what they're doing,
especially about web
development.
JOHN MOORE: Out of everything,
I like the people that I've
met more than anything else.
CATHERINE MULLINGS: I guess it's
the professors that we
bring in and all these big gods
in the industry, and how
they have all these resources
that are coming together, just
putting everything and making
all these connections, and
just feeling the creativity
that comes with that.
It's just really exciting.
CALVIN CHAN: One of the first
things we discussed as a team
is what technologies we
wanted to use and
incorporate in our app.
And we all decided that we
wanted to use stuff that we
learned here at Chrome
Academy.
JOHN MOORE: One idea that we had
was to kind of have some
sort of interactive whiteboard
service that could serve as a
learning platform.
CARA KESSLER: And we're
implementing WebSockets, so
all of our information
is live.
And when you take a picture,
you click upload on your
phone, and it's live on the
computer screen waiting for
you when you get back.
JONATHAN POON: In our projects,
we use several HTML5
technologies, such as
WebSockets, that allow us to
have real-time notifications
between all the users of the
application.
And also, we use getUserMedia
and also for geolocation, so
users can easily take pictures
and upload them to the server
and also know exactly where
they took the pictures.
CALVIN CHAN: So we've
implemented some aspects of
web components and shadow DOMs
using the new Polymer
technology by Google.
CARA KESSLER: So this has
definitely been an
unforgettable week.
There are a lot of things I want
to bring back with me.
I took a course in web
development at school this
year, and I did learn a lot of
cool stuff, but nothing as
exciting and cutting edge
and new as the stuff
I've learned here.
JOHN MOORE: I'd have to say that
it's one thing, I think,
to read about Google and its
company culture and its
company's mission online or to
hear about it third-hand,
friend of a friend.
It's a completely different
experience to have come here
and seen it first person to,
have experienced it, to have
eaten the food, taken the tours,
talked with the people.
I mean, it was just crazy.
I remember the other day, I
think it was yesterday, one of
the groups was working with
Google Maps on their project.
And they had a question.
And I think it might have been
you, you said, oh, well if you
have a question, we'll just go
get someone from the Google
Maps development team to come
answer your question.
And I was like, wow,
no big deal, right?
Google Maps development team.
CARA KESSLER: I learned HTML5
with the guy who wrote the
book on HTML5.
CALVIN CHAN: One of the most
inspiring talks we've had this
week was from Colt about
performance.
And that really hit me because
on campus, I'm part of online
journalism.
And we focus a lot
on delivering
content that's reliable.
And when he talked about the
fact that users usually leave
a page after three seconds,
that really hit me.
Like, we can definitely increase
our traffic to the
"Daily Bruin," which is the
student journalism at UCLA.
We can increase traffic to the
website just by increasing our
performance and decreasing
our load times.
So I will definitely take what I
learned in that talk back to
campus and try and improve
what we do there.
JONATHAN POON: What I would tell
someone who's thinking of
applying is, just do it.
It's a one in a lifetime
experience, and it's awesome.
JOHN MOORE: So if you're
considering applying to Chrome
Academy, I would encourage you
to, as cliche as it sounds, go
ahead and submit your
application.
Because I think that Google sees
potential in everyone.
CARA KESSLER: I would say
definitely apply.
Don't worry about this only
being a week and it taking
away from your job opportunities
for the rest of
the summer because
this is Google.
And I have a job waiting for me
back home, but I'm taking a
week off because this is
a once in a lifetime
opportunity.
And you will learn more here
than you will possibly in a
semester at your university.
And just go for it, and you'll
be happy in the end.
LOUIS GRAY: That was
an excellent video.
It's really good to hear
directly from the students who
have done the work at Code
Academy and hear from them
themselves.
So I appreciate you taking the
time to have their input right
into the show.
So thank you very
much for that.
ALLISON ROARTY: Definitely.
LOUIS GRAY: So when I take a
look at Chrome Academy, how
did you come up with
this idea?
This is the first time, so there
had to have been an aha
moment to really get
this started.
ALLISON ROARTY: Yeah.
Well, essentially, there's a lot
of really exciting things
happening in the Chrome world
right now, and here at Google,
we are really passionate about
developing students and
exposing them to new cutting
edge web technologies.
And we figured that Chrome
Academy would be a really
great way to do that.
LOUIS GRAY: And what are they
learning about this week?
Is it open standards?
Is it the web as a platform?
There's really so many different
things we can talk
about with Chrome that we've
talked about on GDL.
PETER LUBBERS: Right.
Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: So what's
going on?
They've got like three
days, right?
PETER LUBBERS: No, it's actually
the whole week.
So the students came
on Sunday night.
They were flown in from all over
the United States, from,
like we said before, the rising
sophomores and juniors,
from colleges everywhere.
And so they came in, did some
fun activities, and they were
shown the campus and the
Google store and lots
of other fun stuff.
And then on Monday, we started
the actual program.
And so the program is actually
made up of sort of three
different components.
The first one would be actually
learning some of the
new technologies.
So we're exposing them to things
like the latest web
technologies, latest HTML5,
Polymer, shadow DOM, some of
the new languages like Dart
and lots of other exciting
technology.
Paul Irish was doing
a demonstration of
the developer tools.
But really, the latest and
greatest that people might
have seen at I/O, but
that's about it.
LOUIS GRAY: Now I know it's
been a few years since I
graduated college.
But I don't remember shadow
DOM or any of these things
being part of the
CS curriculum.
PETER LUBBERS: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: How would you say
that Chrome Academy introduces
new concepts to the students?
Are these things that
they're learning in
universities already?
What's being taught and what's
not being taught that we're
kind of filling the gap on?
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, and I
think that's part of the
program that is the mission
behind the program, is really
to introduce them to the things
that we would like them
to already know that
they're just not
getting yet in college.
I mean, these things are so new,
to give a little bit of
credit to the universities, they
could not possibly have
curriculum on it because
it just doesn't exist.
But here, we can iterate on
that curriculum very fast.
And we've just built a two-hour
code lab on using web
components in Polymer that
literally was done for the
very first time by the
students here.
So it's pretty exciting.
They really get to hear from
the people developing the
specifications, the people that
are writing the code, and
the things that are just
barely checked in.
So it couldn't possibly
be in any other sort
of curriculum yet.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
Some of the newness, I think
it actually presents a real
opportunity.
When you write for the web,
you have that kind of open
standard where you know you
can write it once, and it
really runs on any platform.
And in the last few decades,
you've seen this transition
away from software-based
platforms, where you write
once, and it works on a specific
operating system.
Are students really grokking
that idea and that idea of
that portability, and seeing
the opportunity there?
PETER LUBBERS: I think
more and more.
One of the interesting things
that I've found is in the
past, I've done a lot of
training in HTML5.
And we would refer to how it was
bad in the past and then
give an example of, well, how
the HTML5 technologies would
make it better.
But what's interesting with
these students, they've never
really seen those old,
bad ways of doing.
So they're actually starting
out fresh.
And it's great to start with
some of the newer technologies
that are abstracting a lot
of these problems.
And basically, it's a much
better experience when you
don't have to think of all
the things in the past.
LOUIS GRAY: It's kind of like
you say, the best way to stop
a bad habit is to never get
it in the first place.
PETER LUBBERS: Exactly.
LOUIS GRAY: And so they're
starting exceptionally clean.
It's a very interesting
concept.
PETER LUBBERS: And I think
actually even better here
than, let's say, starting the
bad habits back with a
two-year-old curriculum.
LOUIS GRAY: Absolutely.
Now, the Chrome Academy
students themselves.
Is this for engineers only?
Is it for sophomores
and juniors only?
What's the criteria to get in?
How did we find these people
in the first place?
ALLISON ROARTY: So right now,
it is only for rising
sophomores and juniors.
PETER LUBBERS: In college.
ALLISON ROARTY: In
college, yes.
And we generally target students
who are computer
science majors.
But for Chrome Academy in
particular, we look for
students that were strong in
HTML and JavaScript and CSS.
So really, anyone who has those
skills, regardless of
their major, could apply and be
considered for this program.
LOUIS GRAY: The Google hiring
process for full-time jobs has
traditionally been exceptionally
challenging.
We get written up on
it all the time.
And we know that's a great way
and a great threshold to get
exceptional people to
join the company.
What kind of recruiting process
and what kind of
application process do the
students have to do?
Did they have to write code in
advance or say that they've
learned specific skills?
ALLISON ROARTY: For Chrome
Academy, we ask for their
resume and transcript.
So we're interested in what
college courses they've taken
already and how they've
been doing there.
We did ask them three essay
questions, short essays.
PETER LUBBERS: That
was my idea.
ALLISON ROARTY: And we also ask
for a link to GitHub or
wherever they're housing any
work so that we can look at
work that they've
already done.
LOUIS GRAY: And I assume a lot
of the students probably don't
want to leave Google now
that they're here.
PETER LUBBERS: That's true.
LOUIS GRAY: And so how have
we thought about that?
How do you get these sophomore
and junior students who need
to go back and complete
their degree?
Is this something where they
have a fast track into a
Google internship program?
What's the end goal there?
ALLISON ROARTY: Yeah,
definitely.
And that's what we've
incorporated career
development components to Chrome
Academy as well, so the
students have career panels
where we brought in not only
junior and senior Googlers but
interns as well, who they had
the opportunity to then ask
them questions about the
interview process, what's an
internship like, what do you
wish you knew when you
were in my position.
We also are doing mock interview
sessions with them
so that they can go through an
actual real Google technical
interview and get a sneak peek
into what that's like, what we
look for, so that they
have a better
idea for how to prepare.
And we're hoping that all 29
students will apply for an
internship with Google
this fall.
That's definitely our goal.
LOUIS GRAY: The internship's
coming up a lot this summer
for some reason.
But I'm hoping we're
able to get back to
how it really works.
ALLISON ROARTY: The real
internship, yes.
LOUIS GRAY: See the movie.
It's fun.
But there are some
differences, as I
always like to say.
PETER LUBBERS: We
do have pudding.
ALLISON ROARTY: That
might be the only
thing that is the same.
LOUIS GRAY: And the
food is free.
But there's other development
programs for students beyond
Chrome Academy.
Can you explain what
those are?
ALLISON ROARTY: Sure.
PETER LUBBERS: Yeah, there's one
that's pretty exciting for
high school students.
For seniors in high school,
there is the Computer Science
Summer institute, CSSI.
So that's a great way.
And in fact, a lot
of the students--
I'm not sure of the
exact breakdown--
that are in Chrome Academy
were previously in CSSI.
So it's a great track.
That's a three week program
where, again, they get flown
to Google and have the whole
Google experience, but also
very code-heavy.
And one thing I didn't mention
earlier was we're not just
lecturing them on
technologies.
That would be boring.
I mean, it would be exciting,
but hours
and hours of lecture.
It's--
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, you've
got to spice it
up with some variety.
PETER LUBBERS: So we've
actually, right from the
start, divided them
up in teams.
And they were free to pick
whatever project they wanted
to work on.
But they have to--
and this is by tomorrow, by
the end of the week--
come up with a complete
web application.
So they're building that.
And so the first couple days
were pretty lecture-rich, so
they got see, oh, these
are great frameworks.
I can use them.
These are technologies
I want to use.
They made up their mind, and now
they're building, and now
it's much more code-heavy.
So we're bringing in experts
to help them when they have
questions about various parts
of their project.
But tomorrow, it'll be
judging the projects.
And, of course, the winners
can get some prizes.
LOUIS GRAY: Yeah, how do
you decide who wins?
I don't want to give
it away if they
haven't finished their--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PETER LUBBERS: Oh
no, they know.
ALLISON ROARTY: They know
what we're looking for.
PETER LUBBERS: It's a rubric.
LOUIS GRAY: Is it just avoidance
of crash or number
of installs?
PETER LUBBERS: Well, that's
a baseline, yeah.
So there are five categories:
look and feel, creativity, how
useful it is, how
mobile-friendly it is.
Of course, that's one
of our key things.
So all of these categories, you
can get four points, and
the winner will be scoring
across the board.
And they're already building
some incredible applications.
One of them is using WebSockets
and canvas to build
a whiteboarding solution
for in the class.
So that could enhance, for
example, a Udacity course that
they might be taking, or an
in-class lesson that they're
doing, where they can
collaborate with their teacher
or other kids out of--
WebRTC is used in another one.
Another one's doing a great
scavenger hunt game.
And from what I've seen so far,
I've been super impressed.
LOUIS GRAY: You're not tipping
your hand on your
favorites, are you?
PETER LUBBERS: No, no, no.
It's wide open.
ALLISON ROARTY: And with all of
our programs, just like at
Google, we're launch
and iterate.
We're very focused
on building.
And we want our programs
to be the same way.
So these programs are in
no way theoretical.
Like Peter said, we're
not just lecturing.
We're not just telling them
about these technologies.
We're challenging them to build
something in a week with
a technology that they've
never seen before.
And that's what we
do across all of
our development programs.
PETER LUBBERS: And the resources
that are available--
this was also mentioned by one
of the kids in the video--
there's when that
had a question
about Google+ Sign-In.
They wanted to add
it to their page.
We literally just walked
upstairs, grabbed someone--
here, come and help.
And Chris Cartland came out
and instantly helped them.
Then he got on the bus
and went home.
LOUIS GRAY: That's one
exceptional thing I enjoy,
especially being at Google
on Developer Relations.
We have the access to people
on every single team.
And so if you want to reach
somebody from Google+, you
know who they are.
You know how to reach them
from Chrome and Android.
And it's a really exceptional
network within what we call a
medium-sized company
here at Google.
And I've already seen a lot of
people really interested in
the next Chrome Academy.
Like, when is the next
one happening?
Maybe there's already
ideas for changes,
how to make it better.
Is it going to be bigger?
Zach from Sacramento was
asking about the
dates for next year.
Maybe we can tell him.
ALLISON ROARTY: We don't
have the dates for
next year quite yet.
I would say for anyone who's
interested, check the Google
Students site,
google.com/students.
And that information should
be available around
the end of the year.
LOUIS GRAY: And one
more question came
through Google Moderator.
What about the seniors?
Why sophomores and juniors?
PETER LUBBERS: Well, we
want the seniors to
already be our interns.
LOUIS GRAY: So they should
already be here.
PETER LUBBERS: They should be
there in another capacity.
LOUIS GRAY: But where can
people find out more
information about Chrome
Academy online?
PETER LUBBERS: So that's
on your students site.
ALLISON ROARTY: Yep.
So google.com/students has more
information about Chrome
Academy, Android camp, Computer
Science Summer
institute, and the rest of our
fabulous internship and
development program
opportunities.
PETER LUBBERS: And for people
that are listening and
watching that want to get
it, that are interested,
obviously, one of the things,
the application wasn't just
your resume.
It was also an essay about
why you want to come.
Also, links to your GitHub
repository, if you have one.
And those things tend to
weigh pretty heavy.
There's also a letter
of recommendation.
So already, if you're thinking
about it, try to have some of
those things in mind that you
can work towards it, not at
the last minute have to
pull that together.
And start doing some of
our online course.
So, of course, we're
on GDL right now.
But this is also where you would
come to find information
about all of the stuff we're
doing in Chrome, Chrome
packaged app series and mobile
and we've got the break point
with Paul Irish and Addy Osmani
talking about all of
the great things you can do.
So get familiar with the
technology I would say this is
very important.
And we definitely look at people
that have not just an
interest, but have actually
experimented with it.
LOUIS GRAY: When you talk about
the resources there, one
thing that really comes to
mind, besides all of the
Google Developers Live videos
we're doing, but also things
like web platform docs,
the Udacity courses.
I think one thing that's
interesting about Google, it's
about finding the information
and making it available and
accessible.
And you look at exactly what
we're doing here with Chrome
Academy, that you can come in
fully loaded, knowing all
about each one of these
standards, knowing about how
they interact with the web
platform and how to make your
own custom applications.
So I want to say thank you very
much, Allison and Peter,
for taking the time not only
to put together Chrome
Academy, but to take the
exceptional time to join us
here on Google Developers
Live.
For those of you joining us on
the stream, you can find all
this information at
developers.google.com/live.
And if you like what you see,
subscribe to Google Developers
on YouTube, and we'll see you
next time here in the studio.
[MUSIC PLAYING]